okay hello everyone
i think this must be our first
design review of 2022
we are looking at incremental language
development for wolfram language
an assortment of different
uh questions and functions
so we talked about until
yep we talked about it last time and we
wanted to do a quick follow-up i did an
inventory on various other languages
because we were concerned about the
argument order and
um the the general finding was that uh
test body was pretty consistent in most
languages that weren't procedural and
there were almost no instances i found
where we reversed argument order between
while and until so i think that makes a
pretty strong case for having
until
be until test com a body
uh if we want to have it and then we
also have danny here as well uh who
wasn't in the last meeting if we want to
talk about
any i think until
until prime q x plus plus seems okay so
the issue is
that
until that's true do this
and the failing case the last case
uh
is what we're concerned about now we've
got nest while but we don't have nest
until
right and that's the next question is do
we need nest until
um
no
don't we already have
a situation where we allow to go beyond
by
one i'm sorry what do you mean
i mean doesn't maybe i'm misremembering
but nest while doesn't it allow us to go
beyond the um
the wild claws being true
no i don't think so no it doesn't the
the this maybe i'm thinking
extra end times
it does oh yeah an extra i'm not sure
i'm not sure that lets you do the
the until thing though like i think even
if the predicate becomes true in that
extra end times i'm not sure if that
means it continues or if it just runs it
end times and stops
right
yes but so what would nest until do so
nest while
does
nest until would be basically the same
as nest while except that it would run
the test
uh
even if the test was false at the
beginning it would still uh it would
still run its first iteration
yeah first iteration okay okay
oh i see the while would fail otherwise
the while would fail at the beginning
and then it will be over or will be over
um
okay so just just so i understand so
until this is true do this
as opposed to it's more do this until
it makes a difference
yes it does
wait a minute which way round is it
until do this until
that at least is the way i've always
interpreted it uh what nick showed up
might conflict
do this until
so
until prime q x plus plus
is what's being said here right
so
you know it's saying x plus plus until
prime q
that's that's why we talked about the
argument order last time
perhaps it would be useful to have the
usage message of wild yeah
by the way why are those sorry the the
font is smaller there than the body font
seems wrong
okay
i mean is there a possibility that to
avoid this confusion we could add
another word
and maybe it's do until i don't think it
is quite due but um repeat until it's
common yeah repeat until it's a pretty
common syntax
pretty common idiom
sounds a bit though like i mean we have
some repeated and stuff like that but
those are very different
yes
we don't actually use repeat
just repeated and repeated no no we
avoided repeat because we wanted to wait
for
um
um
um
let's see
uh
so so the idea is that the usage line of
until would be identical to while but
reversing test and body
in in the explanation
so let's write it
what would it say
be until it first gives true instead of
first fails to give true
right no but it's not evaluates test
evaluates body
then
i'm so confused evaluating the body then
test
repetitively until test
first gives true
was that
i think it's exactly the same thing
except that it says evaluates body then
test when when ryle says about its test
and body otherwise i think it's the same
repetitively
until
test
first gives true
is that right
yes
the fact that we've been so confused
about this and we've managed to go a
third of a century without until doesn't
make a great argument for intel
somebody did bring this up recently in
stack exchange
and was happy that we finally had it
albeit in the function repository
well that's nice what do we think about
this
i mean i mean clearly i've i've liked to
have a concept like this several times
all right well i mean i think it's
harmless to have
and it sounds like
so it would be until
test comma body
and so it's a little bit bizarre that
you would evaluate body first even
though the argument order is this yeah
we could do it until body tests
we don't want to do it we don't want to
do that we don't want to do that we
don't want to do that i think this is
better because it refer
all right
it's both functions while and until are
focusing on the test yeah yeah yeah
all right let's implement this
fine
okay well it's just a matter of
promoting it
documenting i understand okay
um i
this is a tangential point but i
noticed that uh we do have one system
undocumented system function called wait
until which seems to be
buried kind of internally and only
ties into the front end somehow but i
just wanted to mention it since it you
know we have various other while
functions but this would be the first
until function
wait until wait a minute wait until
it sounds like one of our functions yeah
it's a computation no it's a
no it's it's for parallel computation
isn't it
i
don't believe so i didn't deserve it
it's something there's some tie-in
options about whether wait until
operates or not
it looks very much like it's related to
parallel yeah i assumed it was like
parallel
weight all
weight next
weight one yeah
or wait first
well let's ask roman i guess or somebody
can look at the code okay yeah i'll i'll
follow up on that and if there needs to
be a discussion about it we'll bring it
back another time
okay let's keep going
i find it funny that weight next refers
to a first rather than
being called weight first
actually it looks like wait until some
sort of uh
it's maybe some sort of front end thing
it's like it waits for some condition
for up to some maximum wait time
oh so it's nothing to do with this so
something to do with the dynamic
subsystem oh
yeah it looks like there's
some sort of internal tie-in for
monitoring of some things
front-end execute wait until something
returns
so let's contact the appropriate people
and find out what the story is though
um
okay
let's keep going now now i have a meta
question i mean there's a ton of
functions in the function repository and
we're focusing on these pretty specific
ones what what what is determining this
um
so
so this set is a set we went over i've
been triaging the function repository
functions into categories and then what
we're working in terms of following up
on that is going to appropriate
developers so things related to
associations checking in with
constantine things associated with
visualization talking to brett to give
them a first pass through whatever i
mean
danny and richard and a handful of
people have been picking out
potential candidates and i've been
scanning through the hundreds of ones
that go through there and trying to
categorize them so that we can okay so
how many what is our flow rate i mean
how many you know in this
i mean i think how many do we expect to
promote this year
a few tens of functions
well
propose far more but actually promote
few tens
at most
okay but i also think that in addition
to these utility functions
there are some ones that are a bit more
ambitious that we should look at
we're proposing ambitious ones
you just want them put onto the ild list
i guess yeah that's what i'm saying yes
okay yes i'm saying that i'm saying
these are very much utility functions
and um
okay let's let's look at some of these i
mean what what happened to the one i was
bringing up before
about find the position of the maximum
thing in a list yep so that is the third
sub item in this section here oh yeah
look at that well what do you know okay
fine
okay
take after
is this useful
and is there a more general concept
of see the one thing that i wonder about
is
part specifications i mean right now
we have you know in in part
specifications what do we have we have
you know an array we have you know
things like the spans
and um
what would happen if we had the notion
of a symbolic part specification so for
example if we said something like array
this
um i mean this is a little bit crazy
um
let's just say
uh
i'm just going to
put this in as a as a crazy thing okay
what if we had something like that
well what that means is
you're looking for you're going to find
the part that's two after
the position so in other words this is
equivalent
to
some kind of internal
you know
you could do this in two steps
but this is a
symbolic way of doing something like
this
so
what would the part position x be there
is that the notion it would evaluate to
the position of the first x that appears
in the let's see
i see
wouldn't adding two to that be a
completely unrelated position
it's a different position yeah i mean
this is saying
if if we say
okay so let's say
let's say we did this let's say we had
something here that was a um
uh
um let's say
um
uh i this is a very bad name but
selected part of max
let's say
that
and maybe even even it had some kind of
comma n here
the n of those the first n of those
so in other words
yeah
sorry one question about these sort of
fancy indices is how they would interact
with something like data set or with
query
right because with with those you can
have spans and other indices but you can
also have arbitrary functions and those
functions get applied to the list
indeed but notice that those occur
inside single brackets here
you know sure sure i mean it's not it's
not i don't think it's really ambiguous
but i mean two points i mean the first
point is just that i mean if we're
basically
uh trying to emulate that behavior but
inside of part using new heads as
opposed to using the existing heads then
that might not be yeah that may not be
that sensible but so
select for example with a criterion
would be so what we will be saying one
possibility will be something like array
of select of the criterion which will be
the analog of the dataset way of doing
it
something right here
something important is that we should
distinguish part specs and position
specs so i would be more in favor of
having these inside the extract which
seems more powerful
apparently such a nice syntax for part
but yes
that we have these factor these outer
product cases
um
exactly because with an array what does
it mean the max if you are at level
three in an array
okay but but so in this case if i make
this into a data set
then i can say in that data set
select prime queue can i not
yes so that's doing
essentially
symbolic
part specifications
um and nick on our live stream is
pointing out
that um maybe we should invite nick to
these meetings
um
oh it's a neck function as well cases
for matching sub-expressions together
with their positions
oh i see
this is
slightly
oh an example for cases with position
pattern
oh here what is position pattern
what is position pattern is that another
oh it's a special head for matching
sub-expressions
together with their positions
how interesting
oh i see that's an interesting construct
so that that's the thing
where
we're saying in addition to i i get it
now what this is in addition to a cases
where we're saying for example cases of
range of 10
comma blank integer
we're saying
that
as well as
make their part
it's a combination
of content this is a combination of
content and part part position
and and position
it's selecting go ahead
and i was going to say that we have
discussed something similar for replace
the idea of replacing taking into
account simultaneously position and
content
because now
right now we have separate replace and
replace part but not something that
looks at both simultaneously like this
would
right
so the question is
uh
yeah but by the way by the way by the
way do we have a we have trees people
here do we have to trees people here
yep yes we do
okay because i have a big objection i
have a big complaint about trees
um sorry i know this is slightly
off-topic but it's not as off-topic as
one might think okay so i'm gonna i'm
gonna describe my objection about trees
let me bring up something
um
hold on one second here
um
help where is the thing i just was
bringing up
oh here we go
okay so i had a big tree um
his big tree
okay so if we look at this tree i just
want to get the top three layers of that
tree how do i do it
only way i can think of currently is to
enumerate every other position and
delete them
that's ridiculous
so what i want to do i want to find out
you know so i did a tree extract here of
tree level and that even that didn't
work
it's effectively doing tree level on the
tree
well i mean so so if i have my tree here
um i think the difficulty is that you
have to actually modify
like
by the way this isn't i'm sorry
yes sorry go ahead go ahead
this is an attempt to extend the
language of position specs
to include things like tree level
select
i know i know i know this is why i'm
this is why i'm bringing it up it's
because this is a symbolic level this is
a symbolic specification so for example
here
i've got i think i've got my how do i do
if i say tree size
and then i say tree for example yeah
okay so that's got four thousand
fourteen twenty two nodes
okay
so now i want to extract the top of that
tree so what i say is tree extract
of
that tree comma now what do i do to get
to the top level of the tree
all
all
what do you mean that will give me the
whole tree
no do it
that gives you all of the children at
level one
but that's that's all the subtrees
that's not what i want i want the tree
down to level two
right i think the problem is that if uh
i think it's called tree delete if for
the index specifications you could use
all then it wouldn't be that hard to do
because you could just say
uh
that's a grotesque way to do it i mean
you know because we're used to an
expression well actually what would okay
so the question is what's the
corresponding thing for an expression
let's say i have an expression you know
i say nest
you know of f comma x comma seven
and i want to get
what would it look like i see what
you're saying what you're saying is in
an expression if i want just the top few
levels
what do i fill in for the rest because
for a tree
i can just remove it i can leafify
at level n
right whereas for an expression it's not
obvious how you leafify
so i'm saying and
sorry i think the correct syntax for
this will be three delete three three
levels three to six or something like
that
okay so tree tree delete
but i don't think that's the right way
to think about it
sorry say that again tree level i would
say you enumerate the three levels you
want you go three to infinity exactly
something like that well i i don't want
those i want the ones at the top i want
to keep the ones that yeah oh i see i
see i see so three
is it a list or is it list
three comma infinity
or minus one yeah yep
it doesn't work now but i think this
would be the syntax to do that
okay but but so then then what you're
saying is if i look at this expression
here i could as well say delete
if i did that
see in the case of a tree
a tree which has no further branching
has a null in its tree expression is
that a correct statement
what what do we do or is it none what do
we do
okay so let's just look at how that
works so we say tree of tree
um let's see it's the payload
and then so let's say that's an a
and then we say tree
of none comma b
not tree of none comma c correct
oh because that means there is no yeah
there's no subtree going beyond that the
payload is b but there's no sub tree
going beyond it
okay
all right fine
so now
the question is what you're saying is
what i want to do is i want to remove
that's why you're saying pre-delete
removes the sub-trees beyond a
particular level but that's a very weird
way you see what i'm used to thinking
about is i've got a graph let's say this
tree was a graph i would find the graph
neighborhood of the root and i would
just go a certain distance in the graph
neighborhood by the way danny i'm pretty
sure you're maybe somebody else has some
weird background noise okay it doesn't
matter okay in any case you understand
what i'm saying but if i turn this tree
into a graph then i can extract the top
of it by just the graph neighborhood of
the root
yep
and it's very weird having to think
about tree deletion of all the levels to
be able to get that
i think i want a tree top of some kind
or a tree
what should it be i mean it's because
the only place where that makes sense is
at the top
if i'm not mistaken
but you know i just want to give the
example that i've got here i've got a
tree with 14 22 nodes
okay so for example let's ask the
question i want to know how many nodes
are there at each level how do i answer
that
how many nodes are there at each level
from the root
you would need to
compute each level and take the length
of each level
so you're saying that i would say
tree level
no i would what would i do to you you
want like a table of tree levels at
level in
and then you want to take the length of
each of those okay so let's find out how
i would do that so i would say tree
walk through how i would do it so i want
to get
the tree level go ahead do table
of tree extract of tree level
of tree comma list in
just in
and then
into
from zero to
tree depth of tree
okay so let's and then each of those i
want to say length of that tree level
right
yep
that's taking a very long time okay cool
all right well i wanted to compute that
before
okay so that
and
how would i compute does that give me
enough information no it doesn't give me
enough information to know
the um
number of leaves or does it
it does something by one it does not
have enough
no it does it does look the tree size
oh the tree sizes you have done if you
had done negative levels
then the number of leaves would be
level negative one
but you've done positive levels so you
can't tell how many leaves there are
uh we just crashed
there is a bug
tree level zero shoot
that's an unfortunate crash because i
lost a lot of stuff here
oh well
right
the bug
see the bug yeah
okay you've got a crash bug
when there's zero there but that should
have added up correctly right and tree
level zero should be the root node
correct you're the size of the tree not
the number of leaves
yes that's correct i was i was checking
that the size of the tree
is equal to the sum of the number of
elements on every tree level
okay so let's come back here
let's say i want to know
it's very annoying this just did that
it's very annoying
just just so you know
um
all right it'll take us like 10 minutes
to recover that okay well we won't
bother here okay so question
okay so first question is how do i get
the top of the tree
and by the way i assume you're fixing
all this stuff about being able to
visualize trees without getting
where these just nodes there right
yes
is that can i do that right now with
something
okay the sooner that gets fixed the
better
i mean do you have code for it now
no i have lots of documentation
okay
all right
well i i mean
honestly it's quite unusable i mean i
have to convert these to graphs to use
them
in order to
um
okay but let's come back to this
question about
uh about
enhancing part specifications and jose
has made the point that we should be
thinking about enhancing extract
specifications rather than part
specifications i wonder whether we can
save here's a question
first meta question is could we make an
extract like okay so let's say
um i mean this might be crazy but let's
just say that we had a thing called
parts in here that essentially turned
this into
a
an extract-like specification
is that completely bonkers
you have suggested this a number of
times the problem is that we should
not touch the one-dimensional
nature of part
for example you have suggested having
something that extracts a diagonal with
part i i think we should not do that
yeah
what we should do is to have multiple
and flexible symbolic position specs
that attend that are understood by the
many functions that take position specs
not just extract
also delete
replace part
map
so what about
at least in the one-dimensional case
we can certainly have those
work i mean okay so what you're saying
is
that you know we
the two-dimensional case
it's hard to make work for part
because we're not being given
sort of a complete object there because
we're doing this factoring
of you know this outer product of levels
in part
exactly so
for for part is it's absolutely
fundamental that when you have a
sequence of party specs each one is at a
different level so if you have one part
spec that
um crosses different levels it will
confuse okay so so let me just
understand so let's imagine it's select
in a part spec
it is perfectly possible to do the
select at that level just like dataset
does it
exactly but it has to refer to the
elements of that levels that are
probably lists it cannot go absolutely
yes yeah i agree but so does data set
right
yes yes yes
okay so but there's nothing wrong so
what would happen if we tried to support
something like this in part
i mean as long as it is 1d it might
be too old yes
okay so let's understand the semantics
so in the case of data set
the semantics there
are what what is the semantics and data
set what what can you do um
what exactly are the possible things
though
why is this so slow what is happening
here
okay can somebody please report this
everybody i think that's for you again
again and find out why it's doing this
again
it's some kind of stupid startup of some
search system which should be done
asynchronously as i've said like 500
times
um i can do that
okay
all right so now here
okay those are all fine
okay what are all of these
are these hacks
or is there a general
representation of these
so
i mean this has a way of
of working which is um
uh yeah a bit unnatural but but it has a
a way of working um a systematic way of
working so the operators are
characterized by being
um
how is it ascending and descending
right what you have to do if you have a
data set with a list of these um
operations each one
in uh in a in an argument of of the
query
then you need to know which ones are
ascendants and what what which ones are
the same so what we mean by ascending
and descending is they look down in the
tree or they look up in the tree
basically
not really so what happens here is that
you start on the left you start with the
first one and then you go
uh towards the right
and those that are descending you will
evaluate those at that time then you go
to the to the end
and go back and then you evaluate those
that are ascending
so the question here is that when you
have a list of these operators at
different levels in which order do you
evaluate them because
it's not commutative
some of them are going to affect the
levels
and they will introduce a new level for
example group by
so it's very important to know in which
order they will be evaluated
and this is the the
syntax right so if we were going to
untangle this into a function
to apply outside of data set
right what would we do
so these functions
so the problem is quality too it would
be a query as well and it would be able
to have the same syntax
yeah but okay fine but the issue is one
of the things that's happening is
these functions are applying themselves
to a particular level okay so here's a
question
let's say i have an array
um
and i have this array right
what does it mean
if i were if this was in a data set
and i was applying a function f
let's see so
in data set i could do if i'm not
mistaken
i could take data set of this
and i could apply
identity
f identity am i right am i wrong
or for goodness sake
well let's do normal of that
okay what happened here did that do what
i expected it to do
it's applied
at the second level yeah
right
okay how do i do that
how do i do that with some function
outside of data set
to apply f at the second level to
achieve the same result as this
month
at level two
i see what you're saying
you're saying map f onto this
at level two i i i think in this case it
will just work like like this
no it doesn't work
well
map
like two up to
this is this is the the confusion
between apply and construct
so we are
mapping at level one so that we are
applying f to the elements that are
level two
okay so what is the analogous thing that
i should use for this just change the
two to r1
or could i change the map no i cannot
change the map to an apply
um it would be like construct at level
two something like that
is there a version of construct with
level five no no if there was a level
spec version of it
i'm very confused by that wait a minute
construct
just takes f a b
no it just takes f
a b c
like this it's veroags i'm i'm very
confused what would it mean to say level
two
well what i'm saying is that constructor
of f comma x we could say that that's
constructing at level one at the first
level
if you had construct of list a comma b
you could be constructed at the inner
level
at level two
i see
okay i think that's
yeah okay we don't have that option
anyway because it's a verax function but
okay so my question here is
as we think about generalizing
so again imagine that you have this
array and instead of saying identity f
identity you have fgh
the question is in which order do you
evaluate the f the g and the h
because it will change the because when
you do the f g and h
okay let's do that
so this
this is assuming i don't remember
whether things by default are sending or
descending i guess they are descending
by default
and so you see how so it already changed
by the time you inserted the f
that changed
the
level
for the g's
by increasing them by one because you
stuck an f there
exactly correct
well and these could have done something
already imagine that one of these g's
was a group buy so that group by has
already introduced a new level
right but but so the question is does
the okay so the question is does the
thing this is we could have labeled this
so what we could have done here is we
could have given an association one goes
to f
two goes to g
three goes to h and we could have said
apply those functions at those levels i
mean here we could have done some very
bizarre thing we could say
you know level map or something
of something like this comma array
okay
so
i think my point is that so far with
part we don't have these problems
because the only thing it does is part
extraction at each level which is fully
independent each level is fully
independent from the other yeah right
so if we do these extensions we will
have to worry about this ordering things
etcetera
well you're saying if the thing
basically modifies itself as it's
because part
is a layered
con
creature that goes level one level two
level three
um
okay but but let's come back here to
to what we were talking about we've got
this take after concept
which was the original thing
and i'm asking the question why aren't
we doing i mean
clearly if we had sort of more
complicated specs we would say things
like take blah blah select
prime queue
which will be equivalent to just saying
select prime queue of the array
see what i'm saying
um
yes
i'm not sure i would put it in take
but
yeah it's kind of silly intake i'm sorry
i didn't mean an intake because it's
really got it's it's it's producing a
list of indices
well
okay okay so
it clearly would be useful okay
having the ability
to
i mean is this useful to be able to say
that's the equivalent of the of the take
after business
right that's saying
find this as the position
and then do arithmetic on that position
um
well okay i really do think it's worth
exploring you know enhancing our
position specs
because i think go ahead
i was going to say so the
third subsection under here there
is a note about position
index which i don't really ever see used
very much but i don't either
you know is i forgot we even had it
yeah so
i don't necessarily think a
a second argument would be particularly
useful there but trying to think in
terms of
we said you know finding the max
position within a array or finding the
maximum value within an array is a
common operation or the minimum value
there's a handful of operations where we
need to effectively look at the entire
array
and then we want to pull an element out
and
i don't find its position and find
something find its position
yeah
and so there's kind of yeah sorry go
ahead
that's essentially what the last section
is doing
so a problem we always have here is that
finding the largest for example is
potentially a list of positions
the position
and so that complicates things a bit
well okay so i mean one thing we could
imagine is something like
uh
this is like saying okay so what is it
it's the equivalent of saying
um position
of
well it's kind of trivial what
oh i see
position
in list
of f of list that's basically what we're
talking about
right
a function that basically just does that
correct
yes and potentially extract from lists
why do we want that i mean cases would
do
so no i see i see i see i see go ahead
yeah in tech largest we do want to
extract
the largest object not just the position
at which the largest object is
and so we invented this extended
notation for take largest to avoid
having to do several traversals
yup that's the next section here
right and this works well but it's a
it's a non-ver not very standard
notation
do we have this implemented yeah yeah
i don't know
this intake largest
yeah and for example in tech largest buy
it's also able to extract the the value
before and after
applying the function f
um
okay so hold on
i've not used this when did we insert
this when did we put this on
um a few couple of years ago
this was something that rob implemented
i think we use it also in nearest
yeah nearest i have used it
sandra's saying he uses that notation
all the time and it's terrific well good
because i i'm just behind the times
um
i i use it too it's it's quite useful to
get all at the same time i like the
functionality if not
the syntax i mean it's a little
confusing to do list comma all but
i don't i don't remember the original
discussion about why it was done in that
fashion versus an extra argument or
something but
i think take larger store and take
largest buy already have three arguments
and you want to default the arguments
that's the reason right yeah okay
yeah and we wanted annotation that can
be extended to other similar functions
it's like nearest yeah without having to
add an argument all over the place okay
okay
well we already had the one for nearest
for this
so
yeah i mean the bizarre thing here is
that max itself
applied to a list
what it what it would be
doing is having an index
what we're asking for is an index
property for max
in some sense
if i'm not mistaken you know max by
default is returning the element that is
the maximum element
but there's also the index of the
maximum element
right
so here in text largest it's using
effectively max now the thing is that we
have to specify how many elements you
what you want and you don't know how
many copies of the max
element there are
for example imagine that you have a list
with seven
largest elements oh no i know i
understand i understand
right i mean this is the problem that
max returns
i mean it's like communist
communist has to return a list
because there may be multiple
um
maybe multi-modal so to speak the list
may have many modes
um
i wonder how the term mode got used for
the commonest element in something it's
very weird term
okay
yeah so this list i think
i think that's why we introduced the
word take there because we started with
largest
but that seemed to suggest you would get
only one
yes yes yes right no i remember and that
was a good decision
indeed
okay so let's come back again here what
what are
our directions here
one is enhancing part specifications to
be able to look inside at the data
okay so that's a question do we want to
do something like that
the second is
and i mean for example i would consider
up to a huge success
i mean i use it all the time we've
inserted into functions like partition
and you know all this kind of stuff and
take and so on
do do you agree it's a huge success
i agree it's a huge success but i would
say i mean the thing about these other
computations is that up to
like
so i think
if we have all quote unquote ascending
operators or all quantum code descending
operators then it's kind of okay but
once we have both of them then we have
all the problems that data set slash
query have
with having these you know no i agree
with that
so what does what is a
a descending operator
is one let's see rather an ascending
operator those are the more obscure
cases the ascending operator
usually the descending ones are like
are more map-like and the ascending ones
are more reduce like they're like
aggregation
functions
right so you might do something like you
you might map on the way
you know you might
you know map on the way down or in this
case you know select or something like
that and then and then the point is is
that you know when you when you apply
total you want to apply total to the
filtered processed data not to the data
you know right yeah you don't have to
apply so this is my total it's
essentially a map reduced combination
so one feature of the map combination is
that it it does not
change the
level structure
is that true
it could change the level structure you
could introduce another level of list
couldn't you by the map operation
or am i confused
or does the map operation merely
i think you can't remove layers of list
with map
so it's not an aggregation function
but you're going to have i i guess you
you can actually uh that's not true you
you can because you can if you have a
deep list and you map over it you can
get rid of some of the deeper levels
so we have map all that come up at
different levels i think it's first
going to insert the functions and then
let them evaluate and they will do
whatever they do
yes that's what map does i mean map is
just a purely sprinkles the function and
then the evaluator is called and it does
what it does
the difference here
go ahead
sorry
what i mean is that with map we will
insert f once at one particular level
when we map at different levels we have
the question of in which
order these evaluations are going to
happen
yeah exactly so i mean that my point my
point is if we say
you know inactivate
well it doesn't really matter if we're
just just saying
how do i get a an expression with some
depth to it
um
ruby into it
what's that yeah okay some groupings are
all right
actually groupings would be nice
what do i just want
okay so now here
if i say map
capital x
onto percent and i map all capital x of
the percent nine
okay now the question is
what's happened here is all the x's have
been inserted
and conceptually then the evaluator is
called and all the x's evaluate
now
in what sense does data set not do this
in other words how would i get the
expression that is the equivalent
expression to a data set thing with a
bunch of counts and selects and so on
so imagine that instead of having x we
had a list of functions that are mapped
at respective levels
yes and at each level we would insert a
different x and then they would be
evaluated depending on whether they are
ascending or descending we would
evaluate first the descending operators
and then the ascending operator i don't
understand because if we just look at
the symbolic expression generated after
sprinkling so to speak
but
dataset doesn't sprinkle first and then
evaluate i know but could it
conceptually do so
what would it look like what would the
expression look like that is the
post-sprinkling pre-evaluation
expression
i think it would be less useful because
the thing with with
with data set is that is that you may
have a group by for example and then you
rely on that that group buy is going to
be evaluated before something else does
something to the result
i understand that but i'm asking if you
looked at the expression post sprinkling
what would you see
and you're you're claiming that there is
no expression that can be generated post
sprinkling that could be just evaluated
from the top that would give the same
results as data set
yes i believe so
that in dataset it's important that we
eval that we insert and evaluate and
insert and evaluate
i would like to understand that could we
can we look at that a little bit more
carefully and i'd like to understand
that because in other words
you're saying that there is no map-like
thing
that will do the
insertion of operations
that data set is doing
well remember that with data set we have
this compilation
that can express a given query
as
a
sequence of of standard language
functions that would do the same i know
i understand that but i'm asking i'm
asking
if we did it as a static sprinkled
expression
is there a version of this
in other words
i see
if we saw if we looked at mapreduce type
stuff
and we did it by sprinkling
i think we would just see
reduce of
map f comma blah
all over the place
that's what the map and reduce would
look like they could be done
in this way i think
i think they just nest an expression
don't they
when you say map reduce i i are you
referring to
array radius
maybe i am
i mean
i thought our a reduce was a little bit
different
because reduce is a general kind of
operation
that i mean reduce just means you take
an array with some dimension and you use
some reduction operator like total for
example on it
you're mapping from an array type to a
scalar type let's say
yes but but here we are dealing with
operations that are the opposite of
reducing it's for example group by will
produce a new level that wasn't there
right graphite is sort of an
anti-aggregator but but most of the
functions that
i mean i i would say they're like a
couple of those operators like group i
gather by but most of them are are more
aggregation
okay but i think what must be happening
then is that once a group buy is in
there
that the thing that is above it
is not
something which is a predefinable
in other words it somehow gets inside
the the result of group by
in a way that isn't standard function
composition
that's what has to be going on right
yeah it's important that goodbye gets
evaluated at the right time for the next
function to do the right thing i i know
but i think that there is a way of
writing it okay i i'm claiming there is
a way of writing it like this
except that the thing that comes outside
of the group by will not look like f of
group by of of list
it will instead look as you know some
kind of um
weird apply
of f comma group 5 list that's what i
claim
okay and the question is what is weird
applied
i it has to be that there's something
like this that it's doing
right that in other words
okay in in dataset when it is doing an
ascending operator
okay
i am so confused here
you see i think it's i think i claim
without enough justification
that there is an up to like thing going
on for levels
that the reason we run into trouble here
is that there's some kind of thing
which is some corner case that is like
up to but it's about
you know
how we map things or something like that
because there's got to be a way
again there's got to be a way to write
this out
there's got to be a way to write out
query
i'm going to put something in the chat
special operators that's just horrifying
um
can you evaluate what i placed in there
so for example if you have
query with a group by in the middle
that gets converted into that you see
the the various compositions
and mappings etc
so for example the fact that you have a
group by made h to be mapped so that it
it's mapped at the right level that has
been produced by the group by etc
okay i think we need to understand this
more so you're saying
so
notice how things are first f then h
then then g even though we wrote f g h
wait a minute the slash at operator so
if i say f slash i never use these and i
really should be using them
that thing there
applied to x
and the thing is that the data set does
not run it takes apart the the
compositions it doesn't run them in
order
if i give it composition at all
yeah if you give it a composition it
will not necessarily run it in the you
know
it takes it it symbolically takes apart
the composition and may run it in some
weird order
it may even you know it'll run like like
sorry it'll run they're sort of like
it'll run the things in the composition
in the order you've put them except it
might jump down to a lower level then
jump back up to finish your composition
if you know what i mean so you don't
know that the whole composition is going
to be run at once
i think we need to understand how data
set compilation works better
so if you've read for example fgh
you see that things are are
kept in order
well fgh and what and just fgh in the
query yes in the query or it will be
data set of fgh
so
what's that map doing there
so what the heck is this
so that thing
applied to x
you need something deeper
because fgh is it needs to be like level
three at least yep
this is equivalent to running map and
then the mapping function calls map and
then the mapping function called map
applying f at level one g at level two
rachel of three
we're after level zero but yeah
this is applying
the deepest thing so it's the first
thing
so it's applying this first
oh my gosh this is confusing
so
it's using the
okay just so i understand map f applied
to
abc does that
i am fairly confused here i mean in
other words
this thing here
i feel like we need some version i mean
there's a bunch of heuristics built into
query
yes the key point here is to remember
which type of operator one given
operator is
we had always meant to go back when we
originally designed this ascending and
descending things we had originally
always meant to go back and kind of try
to understand with more clarity what all
this stuff meant
sanders commenting the syntax with the
arrow be very useful and select
because it could return index and
element
what would that be analogous to take
largest by
i see so you're saying we could be
saying although
it could be saying select in the list
abc
arrow index
that's interesting
oh let's take an example i don't know
let's not use range because that's going
to do something silly okay basically
here you know hash greater than zero or
something
which is not something we can achieve
with position right now i mean with
position what we would have to do is
we'd have to say
position of um i don't know
and then we would say
x blank slash semi x greater than five
did you need the ampersand oh yeah yeah
okay so that's how we would do that but
the alternative would be this thing
above it with a select returning an
index rather than an element
is that doable i mean in in um
seems like it will be doable same as
take largest buy
i wonder what yeah go ahead sorry
i think the important thing here is to
avoid multiple traversals because if you
want both the objects and the indices
you can get to them both at the same
time
sure although it's also syntactically
nice to be able to say
i don't know how synthetic looking nice
this is because to get those
indices it's a rarer case to want the
indices than to want the elements
um
okay nick is saying you can always write
function composition
over data set you could always write the
query you can always write it
as a function composition
and nick is pointing us to select
positions which is doing exactly this
thing
cool
yeah that's doing exactly this
okay look my conclusion is that there
needs to be a better study of the
calculus of operators applied to
nested arrays
right this has been
in
okay there are two points here
to what extent
can
part specifications
you know
have things that refer to content
that's point one
and how do we think about
yeah i mean
let's let's try to study this query
thing a bit more maybe we can ask tally
to make a special guest appearance
um
anybody anybody want to have further
comments on this perhaps this is
another thing for the data container
discussion
because that thing is going to be closer
to data set and it could
have capabilities that normal arrays or
parts don't have
i agree but i think we need to
understand better look we we've got to
understand ascending and descending
operators better it's been put off for a
decade we need to understand it now
and with our success of um
threading
which i think is going to look looks
very nice
that's a great example of innovation and
arrayness
i think there's more innovation in
arrays
i mean look look at our successes in
arrays we've got nothing we've got up to
we've got splice
we've got threading
these are all array innovations
i reckon there are more array
innovations to be had
and something we need to look for
because i think
what we're saying is
look the main point is
function composition okay so one thing
we could do
is you know f of g of h of array
okay but what we're saying is there are
more sophisticated ways
okay so so a naive thing as we as we
already talked about is something like
a um
uh
you know one naive thing we could do
which i think is like data set
is say
level map level one is this level two is
this level three is this
because that's map all but with
different levels
with different functions being mapped on
different levels
am i right
yes and this could allow controlling the
order because you could start by saying
2 to g and 1 to f
yes
it's a good point
right and so so that would have an
elided syntax potentially
of fgh which means those successive
levels
and that would then be but then this is
okay what would this do so level map
here what does this return this the what
is the sprinkled version of level map
okay so look level map
let me just understand what the
ascending and descending versions of
this would be so one rof two arrow g
okay of
let's say abcd
okay so what would this be
this would be
at level one i mean what i'm assuming
this looks like is
is it is it like this
f of
g of a b
comma
g of cd
is that what that does
well it depends how we interpret level
one whether it's
for example map interprets one as
uh all right okay so let's all right let
me just change this to zero goes to f
one goes to g
okay so yes then that that would be like
that
now this is assuming that they are both
descending so we
evaluate them in this okay yeah okay
wait a minute now you're claiming this
is both descending so then what does it
look like if one of them is ascending so
i i think the way to understand this is
is to
convert into a sequence of maps of
nested maps and then we have to worry
about the order in which we place them
so in a sense once you have a sprinkle
you have already decided
an order which will be the order in
which the evaluator will handle this
but you can express the level map as a
map of science of a map sense of
something okay so wait a minute wait a
minute so another thing to do would be
uh you know changing the evaluation
order
okay so this is my favorite kind of
issue of the day
is um you know
reordered evaluate
so normally
if we did f of g of x normally we know
how that evaluates
but reordered evaluate
where it says for example do so normally
the normal evaluation order is due level
two then then one then zero
so we could say for example do level one
then level zero then level two
but maybe we couldn't because some of
those levels might have disappeared by
the time we get to them
that's the difficulty is that what do we
do how do we specify
what comes next
if we can't use the pre predefined
coordinates so to speak there are
predefined coordinates
you know haven't we seen this before
with covariant
to what extent is this like some kind of
covariant derivative-ish thing where you
know the thing kind of moved before you
you thought you had a coordinate
but the thing moved from under you under
you
and what does your coordinate refer to
now
i don't see a connection with covarian
and contravariant
no it doesn't no i don't mean coherent
and controversial i mean i mean the
notion of
there is a
we're talking about where does the
derivative
in in a coherent derivative
there is a
a where the thing got applied to before
the fluid moved so to speak there was an
original coordinate and then there's a
coordinate that's sort of fixed to the
fluid
if that makes sense
and so similarly here you can imagine
that there's a coordinate that's fixed
to g
but the level of g moves around
because of ambient stuff going on to it
so that's what i mean by that
that somehow
so we have several functions that have
an argument to control at which level
you are doing things like for example i
think it's the fifth argument of inner
yes
so
so it's this sort of at which level do
you want to apply or or right but the
point is that inner
has
it is easy to compute although the
levels that it creates are not what it
started with
they're a simple summation of what it
started with so to speak
yes but there are several possibilities
at which you can
control
which you can do the operation
and you can control the orders of the
first of the arrays
not of the second
yes but i mean what we're saying here
okay the fundamental thing is
our usual evaluation order is what it is
we are trying to for array purposes we
are trying to change our usual
evaluation order
but
again again i think the problem is
labeling
where we want to do something we have
our original coordinates for labeling it
and what
what dataset is doing is it's using some
original coordinate system and then it's
ascending descending things it's like
what should flow with
uh that's maybe a weird way to put it
but yeah i mean look i think we need i
mean this level map thing
um
let's think about this because that
that hopefully what that is doing
or it could also be level apply i'm not
sure
the point about level map
is that it will never change it may
might add a level
to the thing but it will it will never
be the case that
an outer level will no longer be able to
see things of the right structure
underneath it
right because it will have applied that
function f to a series of islands so to
speak on the level below you can still
always look at those islands the islands
might have been encased in f's
and the f's might have evaluated all
kinds of other things but there'll still
be a bunch of distinct islands there
that the higher level function can apply
itself to
that makes sense
[Music]
but then if there's an aggregation
function like a total then the islands
could all be gone
and if you tried then to do a function
inside the result of total your toast
well somehow data set try to autocorrect
when it sees because it knows the
behavior of various functions it will
say oh you are the total so the next
function to apply will do
it actually at a level less
that's why it has all the time these
maps of maps
to correct the level
yes i get it
this is probably a branch of our of our
raised discussion there's another
you know this is operations on arrays
you know we've now got three branches
we've got threaded
what are we calling it is it threading
or threaded
send it threaded right um
okay so we've got threaded which seems
like it's coming to a conclusion and a
great conclusion
um
we've got the data container stuff and
the backing of that
and this is the third branch which is
which is the
yeah i mean this is a good thing to be
thinking about this is how do we apply
functions
at multiple levels
what is the convenient way to apply many
functions at multiple levels
uh and we have an existence proof in
dataset that there's a reasonable
heuristic way to do that
uh
for each one of these things
i mean i don't know whether this is
whether you can also think about this
usefully in terms of type calculus and
so on
to what's going on inside here of what
is mapping you know lists to lists lists
to scalars etc
dataset does a bit of that because it
has a system to
predict the type of a result
given the type of the input and a query
right right
okay well this is very interesting stuff
okay
okay it sounds like actually we've got
another branch here which is
uh
is it another branch the thing of using
select in a part number in a part
specification
i think that's yet a separate branch of
this whole discussion
do you agree
yes though
as i said i would like to extend that to
symbolic position specs which is what i
think would be really powerful i agree i
think that's what we're talking about is
symbolic position specs
well if they are in particular part part
specs of which we only have i see i see
i see i see i see i see right
right you're saying we might have
symbolic part specs but there will be a
junior thing relative to symbolic
position specs suitable for
extract and so on
exactly and that can they can cut across
levels and take diagonals
right
okay well okay this got more complicated
but we've got interesting things to
discuss and we can do some experiments
perhaps nick and others
on things like level map what or
whatever level map should be
um
and and also sorry the the the other
thing is select
yet a different branch
is the possibility of adding
you know arrow results for functions
like select
right is that where would we otherwise
put that
is that equivalent to one of these other
things we're talking about
um
i'm not sure
okay so to which we just make a quick
list
of these things
um
we've got
uh
okay we've got
symbolic position specs
of which the example is extract array
comma select
blah blah blah
okay we've got um
uh
properties
for
list filtering functions
of which the characteristic example is
select
this one here
then we've got
um
multi-level map basically
multi-level
function application
to arrays
it's almost actually a multi-level
you know it's almost multi-level map or
something
i don't know that's not quite the right
name but but um
okay what was the other thing we were
talking about is there anything else we
were talking about here
guys
we already covered the select with
the rule which is the other one
no unless you want some sort of
connection with the
traversal order
yes
well that and the generalization
generalizing
to
multi-level evaluate or something
or level order evaluate i don't know
all right anything else
no all right
thanks all for now see y'all